[Music]
welcome back have you struggled with
hearing while wearing a mask
one local center wants to share the
latest technology for the hearing
impaired
especially during these unique times
let's head to the hearing center
so there are people who believe that
they hear fine but they have difficulty
understanding what's being said
and this is hearing loss hearing loss
happens because
you're getting you're not getting the
full value of a frequency
that is set at normal conversational
value so if you only get some of it then
you might hear
some of the other parts so you know
people are talking but you're missing
let's say the high frequencies that are
going to be the clarity of the word
the pandemic has been difficult for
those with hearing loss for one
it's the mask as people lose their
hearing they rely
on lip reading they might not know that
they've lost their hearing because they
do rely on their lip reading
as we've all begun to wear masks and
have had to wear masks
they've lost that ability to communicate
with people and it's brought about
their understanding that maybe their
hearing loss is affecting their life
more than they've wanted
and for those that have worn hearing
aids the pandemic has been a little
tough
because masks have uh caused some loss
of hearing aids it's very easy to lose
your hearing aid
when you are or certain types of hearing
aids when you're wearing a mask so
that's become
an anxiety-induced event for a lot of
people that wear hearing aids
so here at the hearing center we have
multiple solutions to help people deal
with
those anxieties and those losses a
hearing device
amplifier is a mail order device or
maybe one you can find in a big box
store
that doesn't need a prescription that's
going to lift all sounds equally
and that can be helpful for some people
but it's not helpful for
most most people need a hearing device
which is going to be built off of a
prescription
and that's where we match your hearing
or particular patient's hearing level to
that device exactly product wise we have
been doing a lot of
in the ear hearing aids so we make
custom hearing aids
like this is a representation of a canal
a very deep uh invisible in the canal
hearing aid that we can hide
inside the ear that's not related to the
peanut or the you know the ear that you
know
so nothing can flip off of it so a lot
of people have been taking advantage of
a hearing aid like this as well
so mask mode is something that starkey
has on their hearing aids it's fabulous
it enables when when you know that
you're really going to be dealing with a
muffled voice
we can enable a switch on the hearing
aid to light up
that voice even more so when people are
being muffled by a mask
and it's a fabulous technology that
starkey has really invested in
our goal is to bring great hearing
to people that have had struggles with
their hearing before the hearing
center here in henderson and the hearing
center in pahrump
are having a couple events where we're
bringing in
starkey's manufacturer's representation
to go over some of their fabulous new
technologies
april 6th through the 9th call us at the
hearing center here and we can schedule
a time where we can
organize a demo a free demo of all this
new technology that starkey has built
into their incredible hearing aids
visit the hearing center on south pecos
road in henderson
that special event starts tomorrow and
goes through friday
they'll be offering a free demo with a
manufacturer rep
to join you have to make an appointment
just call 702
456 las vegas now we'll be right back